any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
so it is a great pleasure to be joined
by a brian who did not lose the nobel
prize but instead won the nobel prize
brian schmidt co-recipient of the 2011
nobel prize the vice chancellor
of the australian national university
you may know them as the owls the
fighting owls i believe that is their
wonderful mascot a wise mascot indeed
and uh today brian is joining us from
all the way down under in canberra's
that correct sir
that is correct although i don't think
the owls are a mascot although i like
the sound of it
well that's what the uh the so-called
internet would tell us so
maybe it was retracted the owl was uh
was put out to pasture uh but it is
lovely to be chatting with you today uh
you are my 11th nobel laureate to be
joining us and this is the 10th
anniversary of your receipt along with
past guest adam reese and saul pearl
mutter of the uh of the 2011 nobel prize
so i thought it was about time for me to
extend a proper invitation and one of
the things that's always intrigued me
about you
is your fascination with wine extends
all the way to the most important of all
monikers your twitter handle and i
thought we'd start with a quote from the
very first observational astronomer to
ever use a telescope
in reality to explore the heavens and
that is of course my hero galileo who
said wine is sunlight held together by
water
and i had the honor to uh to host a
conference in 2015 on the relativity
anniversary centenary at galileo's final
villa in florence and he had a vineyard
there where he also said the sun with
all those planets revolving around it
and dependent upon it can still ripen a
bunch of grapes as if it had nothing
else in the universe to do now you have
a lot of things in the universe to do
but tell me where do you find the time
to be a vintner and to explore the
properties of this fine elixir of
dionysus
well uh you just have to make time you
know one of the things about this job
and you know when i applied so the vice
chancellor for americans is the
president of the university not a job i
would necessarily recommend
most people take especially in the era
of covid
it's been quite a
ride for the last couple years but you
just have to um
you have to make time and you know when
i was interviewed for the job
um i kind of went through and said well
okay there's you know
this many hours in a week
i'm going to sleep for about 50 of them
uh and you know uh how many hours a week
do you want me to work and how many
hours do i get to do things like make
wine and anyway i convinced them that i
could still work an absurd a number of
hours uh and make one
and uh yeah you you make time it's good
because you
you need to decouple from you know
anything and everything you do and
obviously um
of course up at our ketry at galileo's
via which uh you know was his prison a
pretty nice prison though
from my standard
uh he drowned his sorrows and wine which
is something you probably don't want to
do
but uh for me it's just a way of
um getting out
and thinking and i often think about
astronomy or you know the problems of
the world while i'm out working in the
vines
but it is a way as i said to de-stress
and get some exercise and just do
something that's a little different
now your handle is uh is cosmic pinot
on twitter and uh harkens back always to
the famous movie from the uh early early
2000's sideways uh where they are really
besotted with either support people that
are obsessed with pinot and pinot people
that hate pinot but i looked up where
does pinot gro and it grows pretty much
and you'll of course disabuse me if i'm
wrong but it grows predominantly in
latitudes between positive and negative
you know uh 30 ish latitude negative
south to negative 37 or something like
that and i note canberra is that in the
middle of that latitude uh band at
exactly minus 35 i believe was that
another part of your choice way back in
the uh in the late 90s i believe when
you when you uh took up residence in
australia
yeah so pinot noir uh i mean you can
grow pinot noir in warm climates uh but
it produces a very innocuous wine it
just kind of produces red
uh
and it's it's a kind of a painful grape
to grow because it's not well behaved it
puts shoots everywhere it has small
bunches it easily gets disease so if
you're going to grow red
uh it's not the not the grape of choice
you're going to use something else uh
shiraz is much easier to grow
but straws needs a little bit warmer to
to ripen properly so here in canberra
canberra is up at elevation um so we're
at my vineyards at
750 meters give or take a little bit so
2200 feet so about tucson arizona if
you're
in the united states uh of course where
i went to university
it's so we have the same latitude almost
a little little further north of tucson
but it's a very different climate it's
much more cool here
uh
and you need to choose the grape that's
appropriate for the temperature uh that
you're at and so
camber is such that pinot is the only of
only one of the major grapes of red
especially 20 years ago when i planted
that you could sensibly ripen every year
i have a little bit of shiraz planted
now it's hard to ripen uh but i can get
it ripe in at least the warm years um
and it's my climate change hedge uh
but yeah it's uh you choose based on the
um
on the climate if you're smart
and uh if you're dumb you plant grapes
that don't get ripe and that's not
that's not a lot of fun
now uh wine is used in uh in my religion
of judaism uh for many purposes but one
of which is to celebrate the fact that
wisdom
improves and people's wisdom improves
with age um and also bread is used to
signify that people that certain
attributes decay over time i wonder as
the you know kind of the the the
appreciation with time is that sort of
storage as as as galileo said sunlight
in a bottle is there sort of a stoic
property of this wine that that appeals
to you that you can grow it now delay
gratification
admittedly this is a little bit loaded
question but but um storing up and
delaying gratification which which uh
sometimes we have to do a scientist is
that an appeal or is it just merely the
pleasure in that and the earthly nature
of this fi of your concoctions
i i really do like the time uh and wine
is time and place
right if you think about it i get to
take wine from italy and bring it to my
house i get to take my product but then
there's this delay it changes over time
it takes years to
actually
create from grape to bottle and then
years more to really evolve
and you can literally go in you know i
go through and uh i do think back um
oh here's a bottle of wine that i bought
in grad school
uh and that wine was made in france in
1982 and so i'm getting a chance to
you know
i guess connect back to you know a
different time and place
uh and so i do i do find that as a
a nice part about fine wine
um of course you don't have that type of
wine every day of the week or if you do
i think you get bored of it i know
people who do but i think you
you use it um
to celebrate occasions sometimes i just
say that uh that long haul that wine
represents i think is to me actually a
really attractive character
yeah absolutely and last one related
question before we
either
turn off our colleagues that are in
12-step programs and or bore other
people what about pairings with food how
do you find uh uh
is that part of the the the pleasure as
well
or is it something to be savored uh
separately as we have in california you
can't have a restaurant as part of a
winery tasting room uh because they kind
of want to separate those two functions
for some reason but what about pairing
with food and so forth is that part of
the challenge the fun the collectibility
nature of what you do
so uh yes and no i mean some wines
really go well with food and others you
know pairings don't quite work well but
i'm not obsessed with it you know to my
mind
um i want to get
something that sensible so i choose wine
that's appropriate when i'm eating if
i'm gonna have a you know a a fish a
really light fish
um i'm not gonna go and get a monster
shiraz because they just don't work very
well together lobster and shiraz don't
work well lobster and chardonnay on the
other hand that's a pretty good
combination so
but i'm not super fussy about it it's
you know i'm i'm i quite i make pinot
noir so pinot noir kind of covers a
broader range of food
uh you can have everything from steak to
tuna and stuff so i you know i that's
why i kind of like it it's a flexible
one but yeah i try to i try to pair to a
reasonable amount but i'm not obsessed
with it
it's kind of a utility infielder as we
would say here i don't know if cricket
has a has an equivalent down under i
want to now go back to your past explore
your uh low red shift uh activity a
slightly higher rent shift than we are
now um so you grew up in mount montana
although i should point out brian uh you
know when you go to the
nobelprize.org site and you look up the
facts about brian p schmidt it says
brian p schmidt has not submitted an
autobiography is there like some time
limit on that that they're going to
eventually come back and you know
rescind the prize or something if you
don't submit your autobiography
well the it's quite interesting because
the actual
piece i gave is quite autobiographical
yeah so
um
it's easier than said to sit down and
and write your autobiography but i'm
still living my life so you know i
figure i've got another 20 years in me
well as long as you get to it um
that's all that matters i want to talk a
little bit about yeah going back further
you were
early years in montana and alaska
undergrad at university of arizona
and then at harvard and then um
basically from there to australia
talk about your dad i i recall from
reading a little bit of background about
you that he was a scientist he was a
biologist involved with fish and game et
cetera um a lot of the laureates
including adam reese uh your your
co-recipient one of your two he credited
a lot of the kind of curiosity and
scientific inquisitiveness that's so
important in his you know kind of uh
past world line he credited a lot to his
dad and um i wonder if that had any
bearing on your career choices
yeah i'm very much a product of my mom
and my dad um so my mom passed away in
2009. my dad's still uh fisheries
biologist still doing some work up in
cannibal
um although he's 75 now so he's trying
to do a little less
so
yeah so my father my parents had me when
they were really young uh my dad had
just turned 20 my mom was 19. i was what
they called a sophomore surprise uh at
1967.
and
as my father started going and doing a
master's degree and then a phd i of
course was
you know on on his side a lot because
there wasn't a lot of child care back
then my mother was working to help pay
the bills because phd stipends as bad as
we think they are now they were worse
than the past i think they were it was
pretty pretty tough
and having a small kid you know so he
did a lot of babysitting and you know i
remember going in the lab and my my
father loved science he was just
passionate about it
and so i got to see that and you know my
mother not a scientist but someone who
was
a very um dynamic person
i'm very good with people and you know
um doing
uh just getting things done it was an
interesting combination between the two
of them so i'm a bit of both of them
actually but but but that time with my
father was um
i think really instilled in me from a
very young age that i wanted to be a
scientist i wanted to be a scientist as
early as i can remember since i was
three
and the type of science you ended up
practicing couldn't be more different i
suppose from for biology you know i
always joke i was such a bad biology
student that when i would dissect a frog
the frog would live you know i was just
not cut out for biology and then you
know you were at arizona and you got
involved with uh with an experiment a
ccd camera that was used in a transit
survey that would later uh believe play
pay dividends for things like sloan and
other things
that seems like a pretty big leap from
you know kind of fascination with fish
and game uh growing up in montana and
alaska too
astronomy was that a product of you know
remaining in the west in the united
states and and uh or or was it something
that had been kindled earlier because as
i say it does seem a little bit at odds
with biology just uh to be to be blue i
love science and i still love science i
could have become a biologist i could
have become i was really fascinated with
becoming a meteorologist
and
so the fact that it was science or
whatever the whole scientific
process of trying to understand
experiment learn
design experiments be wrong you know
modify that type of thing that was
always
what interested me in science so i
actually like science
of almost any flavor the only science
that i i'll be honest that i never
really liked much as a kid which is
quite of interesting um
is
i always struggled in chemistry
uh
not so much the
because it was just very formulaic and i
just i
you didn't get to mix things together
and see what happened because if you did
you might do something bad right you
always had to kind of follow recipes and
things so chemistry never quite worked
the same for me but from
you know i can remember uh
an eclipse
when i was three in oregon
i can remember comet kahutek the failed
comet when i was 6
73
comet west which was not a fail 76.
got a crappy a useful telescope you know
that my parents could afford when i was
probably eight or nine and were saying
jupiter for the first time
uh telescope when i was 13 i started
that calculating eclipses and things
because i was an early computer nerd and
so you know one of the cool things i
figured i'd do is how to calculate when
solar or lunar eclipses didn't wasn't
good enough to do solar i could tell
when they were going to curb i didn't
know where they landed on the earth but
the lunar eclipses i could do um and so
those are the things that i did and so i
was always interested in astronomy i
just never thought it would be a job
because only the smartest people in the
world become astronomers and i clearly
wasn't the smartest people one of the
smartest people in the world and i was a
good student but i wasn't you know one
of the top 5 000 people in the world
i had this
view that i shouldn't probably astronomy
wasn't going to be on the cards but then
i decided
after working at the national weather
service that the forecast office and
things that i was expecting was not as
scientific as i had hoped
and i said oh crap i don't know what i'm
going to do okay i'll do astronomy until
i figure out what i'm really going to do
that's how i ended up doing astronomy
okay and then of course you had the good
fortune to end up at harvard with uh bob
kirschner and also sharing an office
with past guests sean carroll
uh and then we'll get into some of uh
your co-mingling between uh his
theoretical approach to dark energy and
your obvious experimental approach but
one of the things that most tickles me
about your advisor bob
which maybe um maybe you can comment on
after uh the announcement in 2011 that
you and adam had won the noble but i
should say adam was also his student uh
as well uh he made a comment uh and he
said hey what's the strongest force in
the universe it's not gravity it's
jealousy what do you think he meant by
that i've never asked him actually what
he meant by that what do you think that
was meant to imply yeah i mean i i've
heard him say that before the nobel
prize i mean you know it's
when
it's anything a discovery so i'm going
to take it away from the nobel prize and
talk about the discovery
back in 1998 you know so
uh
saul pearl mutters team supernova
cosmology project the hi-z team
were in a pretty brutal battle which you
know um
probably unnecessarily so i mean science
should be competitive it should be
constructive right
and
our battles were largely constructed but
not entirely so and so there was a
genuine worry by both teams that they
were going to get scooped by the other
team and not get the credit
and that force of jealousy
is really really intense about people
and i'm a pretty mild-mannered person
and even i felt it um
and and that goes through whether or not
you know who gets prizes and all these
things
um the world's not always very fair and
it's not um it's something we need to
remind ourselves is that
there's a lot about
luck being at the right place the right
time normally it requires you know lots
of people doing good work but there's a
huge amount of luck involved in being at
the right place at the right time and
and people really do feel jealous that
they were just not quite at the right
place at the right time or or whatever
and i get it because it's not really
fair
yeah i wonder to what extent you know
things like prizes or accolades
contribute to it because you know
speaking abstractly uh does it matter
that uh you know as long as we have this
knowledge of the universe as well for
pure scientists you know we shouldn't
care who gets there first of course you
know for the benefit of the taxpayers
who fund us you know we want to do it in
a timely fashion
but you know ideally i i don't know if
you would agree with that but ideally it
shouldn't really matter who gets there
first of course you could say the same
thing about getting on the moon and
obviously that was a big but um you
would like to think of scientists as
kind of above those sort of petty you
know human desires but uh i think i
think it's almost maybe a misconception
that science is not competitive right uh
that we don't have needs and desires for
uh things that probably stem from just
limited resources right uh what would
you attribute this need to be prior you
know to achieve priority is it similar
to you know nation chest thumping you
know getting on the moon or is there
something different at work
well it depends a lot from person to
person we have a hyper competitive field
there's a lot more people who want to
become researchers in astronomy than
there are positions available
we have a way of deciding
you know who we think is
you know worthy of those positions that
is
uh probably
far from being um you know
the optimal
uh and so people
do whatever they can they're really
focused on on on that that getting
credit for who and what they are
and i think that um
you know physics and astronomy selects
for pretty competitive people they've
had to be competitive to
get into the university and the graduate
programs and postdocs and they remain
they don't suddenly just say okay i'm
there i'm going to chill out now
and be really easy going
so
it's part of human nature competition is
important because it does make things
happen more quickly but it can be
destructive and so there's got to be a
balance between a bit of competition but
i to my mind it should always be healthy
and happy and
you don't want to
it needs to be done openness what really
bothers me is when you get competitive
and then you hide your results and you
hide your software and things then don't
become your they become irr
irreproducible
uh we want the goal is to get the
science and as fast as we can absolutely
and so little competition good a lot of
competition bad
i've heard somewhat to me disturbing you
know predictions about the future uh of
science including things like you know
blockchain technology
being used to produce effectively nfts
of you know the first microscope image
of uh you know a certain whatever gene
or virus or or what have you or you
could imagine the first you know
telescope images of a you know the type
1a supernova and this at this redshift
um would you worry about that or or do
you see as i do also a place for maybe
um maybe
eliminating some of the pressure to you
know beat the person to publication and
all the shortcuts that can entail uh by
maybe you know putting out a result you
know in a crypt in a in a blockchain
format so that everyone could see it
embedded and embedded in digital amber
so to speak do you worry about any of
the new technologies coming online or do
you think that they could have a
beneficial effect for science in terms
of removing obfuscation and and the
deleterious aspects of competition
well like anything there's two sides so
let's say you use blockchain technology
so that i can instantly release my
results out there
and then people can build on that and i
get credit for it through the you know
through the to the ledger system
that would be a real positive imagine i
changed it and said
i i have this with blockchain and i keep
it
in a form where you can tell and prove
that i did it but you don't get to use
it so my goal is to keep you so you know
what i've done but you don't actually
get to do anything with it i think that
would be bad
and
you know proprietary periods are
necessary to a point
but uh ultimately you want to minimize
them because they hold things there's a
balance of you know
of openness versus giving people enough
time so that they incentivize to to to
do the best they can with it
that's a balance we're just going to
have to keep going on
and sticking with the theme of you know
mentorship etc
in your nobel lecture your your paper
what have you you talked about how the
teams kind of agreed or your team agreed
to really um promote the kind of
contributions of young people including
post-docs as you were at the time and
and graduate students as adam was at the
time um and uh and explain that the
thinking behind that because you know um
as you said there is a limited number of
of postdocs there's limited number of
graduate students because i call it the
academic hunger games you know it's like
every stage you go up it's harder and
harder to get a job um uh except
actually for postdocs to be you know
it's actually not so challenging to get
postdocs nowadays it's sort of a
seller's market where the postdocs are
more in control but in the buyers market
of faculty jobs is almost you know we
have 400 to one applications for a
single physics faculty slot here i
assume it's also incredibly challenging
there um is it fair to young people to
kind of you know have the surplus of of
the the second tier to being if you
consider it that just speaking loosely i
don't mean it denigrated in any way but
at the postdoc level have a surplus of
slots only to find this brick wall that
they can't go beyond is that fair to to
young people to kind of artificially
inflate their their hopes or or is that
just a natural outcome of a very
competitive field of academia
well it's uh
as long as we go through
and
people understand what's happening and
and we do understand why it's happening
there's a lot of
research done at the postdoc level there
are a limited number of permanent
faculty spots there's a lot of post-doc
spots the number of postdoc spots
relative to um phd stuff is sort of
found in equilibrium but people need to
understand that uh
you know post-docs are a wonderful
opportunity uh in some cases
and if that's where your career finishes
up and then you go off and
you know get a job outside of of
research that's fine and we need to
prepare and give people the opportunity
to do and that transition well right so
we need to we need to be honest and open
about it and we need to make it so that
it's a it's it's a good thing not a bad
thing
right and i'm here to tell you
i hate to tell everyone
but uh
the pinnacle of my time as an astronomer
not winning the nobel prize it was
actually being a postdoc
right
once you get beyond that then you get
you have to do a lot of things that are
less fun in life right you have a lot of
responsibility so enjoy the postdoc and
you know if you don't become a professor
that's okay
you have done the fun bit and now you
can go on and get a different job
that isn't that and life will be good so
i think we need to be honest open and
transparent and and quit um
catastrophizing it it's okay
not to become a professor you're not a
failure right if you don't because
absolutely
right
yeah some some consider it the uh you
know kind of a consolation prize of a
kind because it is very different than
what you perceive it to be when you're
an undergraduate or a graduate student
um speaking of post docs when you're a
postdoc your goal is to measure q naught
i wonder if you could explain what was
the mentality what was the psychology
going through your mind you were you
were using this this tool and technology
and by the way you had other
opportunities to do other things and you
are reported to have said you know you
could think of no other uh place that
you'd rather be than to be embedded in
the expertise of bob kirschner's group
so i think that speaks very highly of
bob but also of your just tenaciousness
to focus on a single goal what does q
naught uh why were you obsessed with
measuring that what did that imply if
you were successful how you might have
you know not led to the down the path
that you ultimately achieved what was q
not like in the 90s or the mid 90s when
you were working on it yeah if you think
about cosmology i mean and there's the
the off
uh the sanded jess quote as that
cosmology is a story of two numbers h
naught and q naught yeah so for my phd i
was remembering h naught and of course
being able to move to the other number q
naught is your postdoc seems relatively
attractive right
so
uh
it was the holy grail now it was the
holy grail because we thought the
universe was simple and we thought that
curvature
density
and acceleration or deceleration were a
one-to-one correspondence right because
there was only one thing you had to
worry about which was omega matter
and that one-to-one correspondence meant
if you know q naught the thing that you
could easily measure
uh then that the game you measured
everything right so it was the holy
grail my god the beginning and the end
of the universe
the shape of space
uh
you know uh
that's why it was so exciting
unfortunately the world was
uh or maybe i mean for me very
fortunately uh the world was complicated
but you know when we were doing it it
was it was
literally
being able to be part of measuring both
numbers that describe the universe's you
know large scale uh
you know the large scale description of
the universe
so mark twain repeatedly said you know
history doesn't repeat but it rhymes do
you see any uh rhyming iambic pentameter
uh in this hubble tension you know
people are expecting the uh the two
different measurements hubble constant
to agree the early time cmb late time uh
supernova and uh cepheids and stuff that
wendy friedman and adam reese and others
work on they're discordant that's
claimed to be a crisis as your fellow
laureate the late great stephen weinberg
said physics thrives on crises but today
unfortunately there's not so many that
was back in 1989 by the way uh but
nowaday what do you make of the hubble
tension could that be the search for two
numbers except they're the same number
um or you know is there a much more
prosaic thing that might be lurking as
an explanation
i don't know i mean right now it's not a
crisis it's uh i've got the piano out
and i played a note and it's out of tune
it's like oh it's all sounded great
there's something wrong with that e down
there
uh because you know the discordance is
is is there but it's not it's not huge
you know it's not 22 sigma it's
it's five or four you know depending on
who and how you deal with it but about
the level of
lambda detection that you guys made the
first time all right indeed it is and
that's why uh the lambda we we didn't
say
discovery we said observational evidence
for right right
and
you know i always tell the story that in
2000
when boomerang and maxima came along and
i think we always forget about maximum
but boomerang and maximum we're
literally
a day apart
right and those two came out measured
the peak of the cosmic microwave
background
which told us that the universe was flat
and then the supernova measurements went
from being
kind of
four and a half
to being about eight sigma
right when i remember seeing that on
astroph
and going to my wife and i said i'll be
damned we're right because at that point
i knew it had to be right we're not
there yet in the discord
of the hubble stuff now
so
i suspect there's a problem but i'm not
positive and so i cannot yet
tell you
uh is there something funny going on
with you know the cosmic microwave
background and how it measures
uh
the
effectively the hubble parameter and
then extrapolates it back down to low
redshift is there something funny going
on there
i'm still mildly concerned about things
not being exactly as you might expect
between the different scales uh of the
cosmic microwave background but it's not
a huge effect
or is it just that measuring that the
value of the hubble constant in the
nearby universe is really hard and
despite everyone trying hard there's
just something that didn't quite get it
right
so
go either way i really am and i just
don't know
your thesis measurement if i'm correct
involved the physical properties of a
type 2 supernova right um
is anyone proceeding in those directions
anymore as a physical way that's not
dependent on underlying cosmology
because that would seem to break some
degeneracies
yeah i mean the challenge is that people
are continuing to do that but the
physics is hard and so
we thought that the physics was probably
good to
a hubble constant within about 10
percent
i reckon now we could probably do it to
five or six
you know but you need to be down at one
and i'm just i think that in
homogeneities and the supernovae the
asphericity of them those are all things
that make it hard and and using type 2
supernovae is really intensive with
respect to making measurements
um so
it's it's it's it's a harder thing than
supernovae it's direct
but i just worry that the the physics
knowledge there's just not enough people
i think running big codes to
to be sure that we've got the actual
underlying physics down well enough
there's there's dust there's
circumstellar material there's all this
crap you know they're not perfect uh
objects so right or useful
but i think probably not good enough to
do this
question one of the things that i think
made the discovery of your teammates and
yourself the
um uh so pure and and maybe emblematic
of great discoveries in my humble
opinion is that it was basically
serendipitous in other words you were
actually setting out to measure the
opposite of what you you did measure so
confirmation bias is sort of uh as sort
of filtered out to some degree and i
wonder and i worry with the hubble
tension being what it is now everyone's
looking for their theory to confirm you
know these measurements rather than the
other way around and so by by its nature
it probably can't be resolved in such a
pure way as say the dark energy question
but that's that's just an aside i mean i
i view the serendipity serendipitous
nature of that discovery is quite
striking and reminiscent in a rhyming
sense of the cmb's discovery which was
also
the serendipitous itself um in your
lecture
in your nobel lecture um you uh you
start off with uh with an up a brief
overview of 20th century cosmological
models and you talk about einstein in
what he called his wonderful thought
that inertial and gravitational
acceleration were equivalent
and i remember uh knowing a little bit
about that as a younger person and i
believe the quote kind of was prompted
by his realization that if you were in
free fall you would have uh you would
experience no gravitational forces
and even if you were near a gravitating
body and so
he called that his wonderful thought um
i want to talk about artificial
intelligence because there's a lot being
made about artificial intelligent
physicists and then they'll be able to
there'll be an artificial ai einstein
a-i-e-a-e and there'll be all sorts of
great things but that quote that you
quote and and this the preceding
sentence about you know falling in a
gravity it doesn't strike me as
something a computer could identify with
first of all happy thought a wonderful
thought what does that even mean uh it
seems uniquely human uh and also the uh
the notion of falling in an experience
or you know visceral sense literally
that prompted einstein do you think
artificial intelligent physicists can
make
an einstein-like contribution can they
you know create the laws of general
relativity from just observational data
or do you think we're it's being a
little bit too much wishful thinking
well certainly ai as we are right now is
nowhere near i mean i think people have
to remember that uh ai right now is
really just interpolation
and it's a fancy interpolation
it does not extrapolate at all right
so one of the reasons why
um self-driving cars are a problem are
edge cases where humans can extrapolate
and say
i've never seen this before but i'm
pretty sure i know what's going to
happen and i'm afraid that your machine
learning algorithm says i've never seen
this before and here's your answer it
has nothing to do with anything
so
uh so current versions of machine
learning not hopeless right
it's about finding patterns in in data
that you have so it you might discover
new and interesting things but you're
not gonna it's not gonna have that
aesthetics that einstein had of seeing
some poor guy fall off a house and say
hey that guy
is uh doesn't feel gravity what a
wonderful thought as opposed to i should
probably call the ambulance and help
that guy out because he's probably hurt
so that aesthetics
is certainly a long ways away now you
know
computer artificial intelligence may
become much more
um human-like in the future but it's not
there anywhere there right now so i
could imagine it finding little patterns
and data and what i think might happen
is you'd go through and you'd say i
suddenly can predict something in
physics that i'm surprised i can predict
why can i predict that we can go through
the you know the different layers of the
neural net
and say ah there's a pattern in there
why is that pattern there and then we
would go through and use human
creativity to try to understand it
that's that's how i think it might
happen in the first instance but i think
we're a long ways away from
computers
disintermediating uh physicists
entirely
yeah yeah i agree i often say i think
you know computers can beat humans at
chess but i don't know if they can
invent the game of chess
um i want to turn back to uh competition
you you said in an interview with a
fellow brian astronomer brian green uh
earlier this year you said that the
atmosphere between the taize and scp
teams was toxic at times and you
regretted that and you said you were not
proud of it now you were a poster you
weren't you know you weren't afraid
there were many faculty members on each
team um why why do you say that you
personally weren't proud of it and um
and what were some of the benefits of
that competition as ultimately uh proven
out uh by the solidity of the discovery
yeah well
and when i was a postdoc but i was the
leader of the the team and
i guess
i was friends with a lot of people on
saul's team uh and so we kind of joked
and you know all going through our do we
have jobs you know these are the
questions we used to talk about
but the
the
i guess the toxic thing is just to me
it's embarrassing right it's
embarrassing because it did not need to
be that way
and
we're out there ultimately being role
models for students and people watching
what's going on and that
uh that's not what you want
your
life to be like in science you don't
want it to be toxic you actually want it
to be i should say
a bit of competition not bad but you
want to be friendly right and and so
that's why i guess um i'm embarrassed by
it i don't think it
ultimately interfered in any person's
you know
job prospects or things that didn't we
we didn't get into it where it became
personally destructive but it was
unpleasant and unnecessary
can you offer any ways to you know have
a large large
stem professional audience that you know
is probably dealing with many of them
are probably dealing with such things
now
um can you not specifically to that to
that
you know rival battle
but you know kind of in general how can
you de-escalate conflict how can you
um you know check these prejudices that
you may have or biases that you may have
as a scientist you know we're not known
as i always joke you know how do you
know a scientist is outgoing because you
know they look at your shoes when they
talk to you
but how do you you know how how could
some of my listeners you know diffuse or
detoxify uh if such a thing is possible
remove the tannins
give me some
give me some techniques or tools that
might be
have been beneficial but as you say it
wasn't ultimately uh devastating but
could have been better both for the
younger students witnessing all this uh
but again i don't want you to speak
specifically about that event just
generally speaking how can you how can
we as scientists detoxify a toxic
situation well the first thing to
realize is that whenever uh
you're feeling anger and emotion you're
not being a scientist you're being human
and that's fine but it it gets in the
way of the science tis the science in us
uh
trying to uh
allow people easy outs
uh when they've screwed up rather than
humiliating them in public
uh
either via twitter
colloquium's
front page of new york times whatever
your flavor is
won't humiliate people it's a bad thing
to do even when they're wrong
tell them nice and gently not this isn't
good
uh and and see the world through other
people's eyes be human about it and say
the golden rule
do i if i were
do was this how i want to be treated
right and generally speaking when you're
really angry
you know chill out don't send the email
have a walk around send it tomorrow
chill out and be
[Music]
analytical about it and and take the
emotion out of things as best you can um
because those things set us back and
they
you know they're
they take the joy out of uh out of
science if you get it wrong and
and for those of us in power
like you know i'm i i have a lot of
power now that i uh didn't have when i
was younger
uh you have the power to
you know one of the things is not to use
power when you have it but the other
thing is to intervene you know at a
colloquium when people are beating up on
the speaker and piling on
stop it
say okay i think we've got enough on
that let's let's let the speaker move on
and
uh you know you can you can intervene
uh when when things are not right you
know and
we need to
we have still a lot of bullying within
our communities
um and it's really hard
to exercise power against others
in this intellectual sense but it's
basically humiliate them and then and
that's you want to avoid humiliating
people yeah
um and talking about accountability and
uh and transparency and really ownership
um last week you had a tweet thread
several tweets about uh trying to
understand your own decision making an
involvement in an archive article today
and and you apologize for not thinking
so much about it
and your mistake is that your
participation will provide value to that
question can you explain
why that what this article was and and
why it's significant it's an article
about about sort of job and and research
impact and astronomy how do you predict
it first what was the conclusion that
maybe you regret being a part of or can
you can you clarify this you know as as
you did on twitter to some extent you
know that you took ownership of this
decision and wanted to uh you know
apologize in some sense can you can you
talk a little bit about this situation
brian yeah i'm happy to talk a little
bit around it um this is you know this
was uh
something proposed by john cormandy
where he wanted to calibrate um
citations with a group of people uh
from different fields to just sort of
you know say what is
an individual's scientific output
relative to their citation output
now i was
at the time i hadn't really thought
through
what what exactly that meant uh when put
onto paper
i was interested in just the whole
notion of overuse of citations and
boiling everyone down to citations
uh in all sorts of ways and i was
worried about that so in some sense uh i
was interested in seeing
are we going to find out that planetary
science has a very different citation
curve than
uh cosmology and things like that right
and i wasn't really thinking through
the notion the social construct of
having
you know 21 elite people
very uh
very homogeneous group of 21 people when
you look at it
uh casting and you know putting
ourselves in that position of power and
saying we are god and and so the tone of
the the paper ended up being
something i was pretty deeply
uncomfortable with and i just hadn't
really thought through and i wasn't i
will say john gave me every opportunity
to understand what he was doing and and
i feel like i've let him down because i
did not
uh pay enough attention to understand
what was going to come out
uh but i am very
concerned about um
using only those types of measures that
make us hyper competitive there's
gatekeeping that i talk a little bit
about in the tweet where it you're only
really you got to get the break to get
into the university to get to the phd
lab to get the prize postdoc to even be
in this bit and so
there's a whole social thing there that
i think that paper
missed out on and i know uh having
talked to john i think he's pretty upset
uh and he's
caused
he didn't i don't think he wanted to
cause that amount of upset um but in the
end i should have thought through what i
did and realized
uh what we were doing uh was was
probably uh very much out of touch and
out of tone
of the community we want to have which
is we want it to be inclusive and we
want to support excellence but we don't
want to gatekeep excellence which i'm
afraid a lot of what and how our our um
our field and academia in general works
unfortunately is it tends to
only give
opportunities to those who have had
opportunities ahead of time
matthew effect
um
on display uh thank you very much for
that and as i said in my response to
that tweet to your candor and ownership
because i think it's very rare and i
think that's a teachable moment if you
will for young people
to you know to see that you can i don't
say making mistakes but that uh but that
we're human beings as you said earlier
when you have any kind of emotion
there's a there's a disservice done by
assuming that we're just dispassionate
observers of factual rational reality i
think that's that drives a lot of people
away um yeah as jim gates said when he
was on the podcast he was like i never
thought i'd be einstein but that's okay
einstein wasn't always einstein uh and i
think it we promote that myth of of you
know infallibility to our detriment
because i think it does exclude the
broadest panorama possible i want to
wind up because i know you only have a
few minutes left but i want to um uh
just kind of um
touch base with as i said this this
notion that you found it very important
to have an intellectually diverse um
set of team members on your team uh
including theorists and and physicists a
gasp physicist involved uh including
your former office mate uh well your
former office mate was sean carroll he
wasn't a member of the team but people
like chris stubbs and and other folks um
physics uh and astronomy hybrids etc uh
but theorists talk about the importance
of that um and
and how what role that plays and having
a true you know panoramic synoptic view
of a field uh does it require that or
can we put our heads down just talk to
you know those of us who are like those
of us and uh and make a lot of progress
because we know we have theorists and we
have you know data scientists working on
it uh but it's not clear that you know
all my students are all i say and this
is probably my fault but that they
really have kind of the broad scope of
history and and all the different
panoramic contributions that are
necessary to make a huge caliber
discovery so maybe yeah comment on kind
of breath versus depth if you will and
the importance thereof
yeah it was a big project and i really
appreciated having
a bunch of people with specific skills
and some people who
uh you know could see things from the
different part and so i did really want
to have that
intellectual diversity and and you know
fessing up
we had 20 people on the team but no
women so we didn't we didn't get it all
right and uh i could
go back
in time and fix that as a 27 year old i
sure would because i think we
you know
that was part of our uh uh you know a
missing part of our our team when i when
i look back at it
um so
if you're gonna solve
problems if they're simple cop problems
okay you just you know you have a hammer
you smash the nails
this was really hard because we were
having to do a whole bunch of things
we're going to having you know to
schedule people and telescopes around
the world were having to write software
that had not been written before we were
having to process the data really really
fast we were then having to set it
across and then do a very detailed
analysis and
you know we did a full bayesian analysis
in 1998 it's literally one of the first
ones of those ever done and i wasn't
taught that and you know adam
kind of teaching me via bill press on
the phone and we were only able to do
that because of that diverse group of
people came together
um and so you don't really know you need
diversity but it's always useful and as
i said i i regret not having a more
gender diverse team it's one of my big
regrets and all of that
um and lastly i want to know what is
your daily life like now i mean
modulating out kovid obviously that's
hopefully a
you know time limited duration limited
thing and australia's uh you know
reaction
notwithstanding in terms of you know
uniqueness versus the u.s but what is
what is a vice chancellor which as you
say is tantamount to president here in
the us or chancellor here um talk about
what what is that uh life like is it how
do you
go from astronomer to vice chancellor
because it seems like you would have to
do a lot of reading or
maybe uh
you know
change gears radically so so talk about
that change from
astronomical group leader to now you
know academic academician as we would
say yeah well it was it's a big jump um
ultimately
being a leader of a university in
australia it's a little different than
the u.s president because you've got the
outward bit but a lot more of the inward
bit too so it's sort of the president
and the provost combined
uh so i had to learn a lot you know how
do university budgets work really well
how to uh you know how do you improve
the processes in a university and all
these business-like things but
ultimately it comes down to people
right being ahead of a university is
ultimately about empowering rather than
just your group
all sorts of groups and all sorts of
areas and getting to work constructively
together
um and and getting things done so the
the work i did with people um i think is
the single most important part about
being a university leader but then you
have to learn some of the mechanical
bits around you know how do you how do
you run a billion dollar organization
and you know listening and talking to
people who do management and talking
about it is important but we also have
to remember universities are not
companies and so most of the management
theory you're going to learn is all
about running a company
and i'm telling you that's not what a
university is
i mean and a lot of universities have
become like companies but then i don't
think they're very good universities
they're machines for producing
undergraduate degrees or something so
uh it's been an interesting journey of
learning for me
but in the end the rules around a group
of six
actually apply to groups of five
thousand
um
treat people with respect listen to them
understand things from their perspective
and try to get them to play nice in the
in the sand yard uh in the sandbox with
each other that's sort of the goal
uh and then of course uh get out and
tell people around the world what you're
doing and why it's exciting and you know
that's sort of my job
in fortunately many many hours a week
do you miss the telescope time do you
miss the
teaching or
academic uh pursuits of a researcher
more
than than you thought you might or are
you comfortable kind of not being in the
in the day-to-day grind of astronomical
professional astronomical life
i mean i knew i was going to miss it i
knew what i was signing up for um but
you know i've been out now for almost
six years and yeah i'm really beginning
to miss it so yeah i will i will be a an
astronomy professor once again but i'm
gonna have to come into some of this you
know rebuild myself for several months
to get my skill set back up and that
will be interesting and so
indeed so you know uh it's here early in
the morning and my uh
my first meeting of the morning is
starting in uh 90 seconds then it's back
to back for the entire day
okay i'll take that as an opportunity to
ask you one question in my final three
patented questions if you'll be so kind
i want to ask you
uh brian if uh if you can summarize kind
of uh what you would put on a so-called
monolith arthur c clarke had these
monoliths in 2001 they're kind of time
capsules they're kind of uh devices
meant to ward off uh
can you say what
advice what piece of information would
you most want to put on a time capsule
to last a billion years
[Music]
the future is more important than you
think
all right that could also pass from my
advice to my advice to your former self
uh the only way of discovering the
limits of the possible is to venture
beyond them into the impossible origin
of my podcast name brian schmidt thank
you for spending time with another brian
uh on sharing some of your valuable time
with myself and my audience i can't
thank you enough
great thank you very much take care
thanks brian
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic